have you done any research looking into
stem cell infusions for autoimmunity or
NK cell infusions not a ton I know that
it's an option so when people are unwell
the stem cells can regenerate things or
make things better in the system I know
that some people use adjunct therapies
with carnivore and I'm supportive of all
of them even if you use CBD at night
melatonin I mean melaton is kind of a
hormone so I'm just a little iffy with
that that's also affected by sirs I
always say get to root cause so why do
you need these stem cells right if you
think about a couple hundred years ago
no one needed that if you want to use it
to have longevity and live longer and
healthier maybe but if you're doing it
because you're not unwell then figure
out what's making you unwell first and
then if you want to use it totally
supportive